hey Bridget meaning something that's
fitness we're gonna get Andrew doable
GQ assistant editor out of this meeting
and see what's up in slavery hey good
well notice you're wearing so pants to
the office today I am I feel good I
could run right now I can run down this
block which is like kind of how I feel
like usually in my jeans I'm like stuck
to this and now I could like to like a
full on like down in squat let me ask
you a question how did you choose to
wear them to make it feel like I might
be able to get away with this bigger
with the shoes and I normally would big
with the shoes I don't think with me I
want to make it look like I was put an
effort damn pleasure mr. rubble thank
you well I think you look no no no but
we'll see okay
alright guys so there you see a pair of
tailored sweatpants actually in the wild
here in the GQ office we've got designer
John Eliot here we're gonna get into it
further with him I personally and like
sometimes not so convinced that like
America is ready for sweatpants all the
time so should we talk about some
hypothetical instances and whether or
not sweatpants on the move absolutely
you into it yeah that's it all right
wearing sweatpants to the office you
need the proper fit yeah and then you
want to style it with something smarter
right um potentially like some type of
button-down maybe like a blazer over
that yeah I would say like in general
you need to do something now like
respects the context of the office you
got a hot date sweatpants I felt like
women and children like hiding their
eyes you wear them slim and kind of like
slouchy through the crotch and you
wearing kind of an oversized t-shirt
with maybe like a leather jacket on wrap
you know don't wear ratty shoes yes no
busted out shoes
yeah no busted shoes what about hard
bottom shoes with weapons not a
navigator not an everything okay cool
okay so wearing sweatpants to the club
oh yeah I've done that before
first of all did they let you in yeah oh
yeah you pay them oh look it wasn't
intentional showed up to the airport
late my bags in
on a flight I have more conversations
about what I was wearing that night than
I do on it on a typical night in the
club how would you John Elliott suggests
a guy Styles it up to make that a
success slouchy oversized t-shirt kind
of like a statement piece with the
leather jacket maybe the sweatpants are
black so there's like that less
attention and you're just kind of like
mom adding her keep it all black that's
that's a good look last but not least
wedding look dude if you're gonna go to
a wedding in sweatpants you might look
back on that in 10 years and be like
shitty move right if you don't love this
couple I'm gonna run the other way let's
run the other way just just over the
floor okay you're gonna have so much fun
you're gonna be the hit of the party you
can dance you can move you're gonna look
dope like you're no one's gonna take
your picture that's a way subscribe to
the GQ YouTube channel if you haven't
already
leave a comment call us on the telephone
send us an email send me a text message
wave to us as we pass on the street
we'll see you next time